[Music]
[Applause]
chris mannix sports illustrated senior
nba writer he was there for game four at
least we there was a rumored game for
eastern conference finals last night
heat in the celtics he's been on site
for the entire series and chris joins us
this morning at what point do you think
eric spoelstra said to his starters guys
come on over here and sit with me the
rest of the night
uh
well i i think the first sign of panic
was probably when duncan robinson was
inserted into the game early i mean
duncan robinson has kind of been the you
know break glass in case of emergency
guy uh in these playoffs he hasn't had a
meaningful role in there he was i think
early in the second quarter
um with this miami heat offense unable
to come up with anything
in that first quarter i mean dan they
had one point through the first eight
minutes of that game if not for victor
oladipo who you know just rejoined that
team in the final weeks of the regular
season going off in the first half
like they would have been single digits
like nothing was working for that team
offensively so i think eric spoelstra
probably had a hankering something was
was was bad uh early in that second
quarter but you know we have these
different you know these highs and lows
with both teams where you're going to go
boy they're unbelievable then you'll go
boy they're unbelievable
i don't know what to expect i'm i said
this from the outset i thought miami was
going to win in seven
now you go back to miami
i don't know who's healthy i don't know
what to expect
how do you kind of uh handicap this game
well that's the biggest question right
who's gonna play um you know marcus
smart uh obviously that ankle injury is
significant he was limping down the
hallway at the garden last night before
the game so
is 36 hours or whatever it's going to be
before he's deemed available going to be
enough he's going to take a long
longish plane flight down there is that
gonna do him any good robert williams
was great through three quarters in game
four but he left the game in the third
and was noticeably limping and he's been
in and out of the lineup as well those
are two big factors in all this tyler
hero on the other side is he gonna play
now like all things being equal dan i
think boss is the better team i think
they're frankly the much better team in
some ways
they lost game three not because they
were outplayed because they kept turning
the ball over i mean they had 24
turnovers in game three that led to 33
points from miami miami had 29
deflections
in that game that was a playoff high you
know for the year boston was just sloppy
so when they take care of the basketball
like they did in game four where they
had three turnovers in the first half 11
overall
they're just the better team so if the
celtis can get you know rob williams
marcus smart back on the floor and keep
the turnovers low they're going to win
in miami what do you expect tonight from
golden state in dallas
i don't know if dallas has answers you
know for for golden state at this point
um
you know the wars just seem to have
their number they're a much more patient
offensive team than any of the ones that
the mavericks have faced uh in these
playoffs um defensively they've done a
really nice job overall on luca doncic i
think andrew wiggins had a good series
overall uh you know this is just kind of
that
this is this mavericks team ceiling like
they've reached going up against golden
state with that kind of firepower that
kind of defensive versatility this is
kind of
what shows
nico harrison jason kidd and the rest of
the organization how far they are away
because as great as luca is
you can't beat a team on golden state's
level with just luca and a bunch of
shooters you've got to add something
else to make you more dangerous but what
is that in the off season what is dallas
capable of adding to that roster i don't
know i don't know what they
you know they they have some
trade pieces that might be of appeal and
you can also say another full training
camp with spencer dinwiddie might be
useful for that team but look they're
going to pay jalen brunson
to bring him back
and other than that they don't have a
lot of
marketable assets that teams would would
clamber for i mean nobody's coming
running for tim hardaway jr you know to
to trade for him but is luca going to be
somebody that players want to play with
yeah absolutely but players want money
more and they want um
you know long-term high-value contracts
more i mean he's going to be able to
draw in free age there's no question
about that but ultimately i think what's
going to come down to in the years to
come is how dallas drafts i mean look i
mean look at these series right now i
mean i mean golden state we know their
draft track record over the years with
draymond and clay and guys that weren't
necessarily blue chip prospects
including steph uh by the way but look
at boston right now i mean they're in
this series in part because grant
williams who i think was what 22nd in
his draft is playing excellent rob
williams was like 27th if i'm not
mistaken um you know peyton pritchard
has played well at times during these
playoffs derek white was a you know not
a sexy mid-season acquisition he was
brilliant in the first quarter last
night so it's it's going to come down to
these diamonds in the rough that the
mavericks can kind of mine and add to
that group around luca
yeah i just wonder like zach levine's
going to be out there
i don't know if rudy gobert is going to
be available i i just
luca is
i hate making the comparison but there's
a james harden feel to him that he's
ball dominant i'm talking about
houston's james harden and
you know he makes others better i just
you got to be patient with him because
you you're not quite sure is he going to
throw me the ball not going to throw me
the ball and that can be frustrating i
would think for players
wanting to play or not wanting to play
with a ball dominant guard
yeah and look the guys you mentioned i
don't think they're the answer i mean
zach levine
he'd be a scary contract this offseason
because of the injuries he's had and
he's going to want max money rudy gobert
doesn't really do anything for you the
mavericks just beat up on rudy gobert
with maxi klieber you know playing the
five spot in in that series i look
you know you mentioned harden
he did have his best team success with
another ball dominant guard playing
alongside him i mean his couple of years
with chris ball were the most successful
team years of james harden's career
houston so just like harden i think luca
can play
with that type of player the question is
is that type of player someone you add
to the front court is it someone in the
4-5 slot where they are
a little one-dimensional offensively is
again spencer didn't what he's the guy i
mean didn't what he was great great for
that team since being acquired from
washington mid-season is is he have
another full training camp in a full
season does he become even better it's
tricky there's no question about it but
again i think you're seeing the
mavericks ceiling with this point they
they're capable of getting to this point
but getting past it i think is going to
be difficult talking to chris mannix
senior writer for sports illustrated
covering the eastern conference
your uh reaction when javon howard
passed on the opportunity to interview
for the lakers job
i mean it's for multiple reasons right
like john howard you know probably not
only doesn't want to step into that mess
he also has his kids in ann arbor so i
think there's
there's a duality to it in a way but it
is a mess that
not a lot of coaches
are eager to
jump into i mean
what are we talking about with the
lakers what are the lakers going to look
like two years from now is lebron going
to be there is anthony davis going to be
there are they going to be in the in the
full-scale rebuild
early on i mean there's just there's
just too many questions even if
dan even if you think the lakers are
going to remain intact for the next
three years how good is that team like
what is the ceiling what can a coach
come in and do frank vogel was a
championship coach he led them to a
title just a couple of years ago is
another coach going to come in
and be a difference maker with that
group i mean terry stotts is a fine
coach he's more offensive oriented than
defense is he going to fix the defense i
think darvin hamm
deserves an opportunity to be a head
coach but is he going to be the guy that
brings all that together there's just
it's just such a combustible situation
that unless you are going to
staggeringly overpay the head coach of
that team which it doesn't sound like
the lakers are willing to do they're not
going to do for a head coach
what minnesota just did for tim conley
the new gm up there and giving them
eight million dollars per year they're
not gonna do that in la right now so
unless they're willing to do that um i
don't know what kind of coach you're
going to get and if the reports are
correct that you have to make russell
westbrook
work in this system with the lakers
um i don't know how you make him work do
i think if lebron lebron and a.d can get
you into the playoffs i don't know what
russell westbrook's role is like to make
him work uh how about you make some
shots that would be a start but i don't
i don't know how you can get rid of him
get out from underneath that you know
the laker coaching staff um
i was hearing late last year you know
talked to russell westbrook about
kind of making the transition turning
the corner on one phase of his career
and going to the next whether it is
becoming a sixth man or whether it is
becoming more of a spot-up shooter and
how it was explained to me
was just
like falling on deaf ears like russ is
still going to be russ out there he is
still going to play
his way now you may be able to make an
accommodation for that if you tell him
from day one you're the sixth man you're
coming off the bench you're playing 25
30 minutes per game you're doing it
against second unit guys and look if
you're playing great down the stretch
we'll probably leave you in in the
fourth quarter otherwise you're coming
off the floor in favor of a more
complete two-way type of player that's
the only conversation i would have with
russell westbrook if i knew he was
coming back is that you are going to be
a sixth man and dan you and i both know
that can extend his career like russell
westbrook can probably play three or
four more years as a sixth man he still
has that level of talent in him if he
still thinks he's the mvp if he still
thinks he should play 35 minutes per
game that's just not gonna work
i said it from the outset i would have
brought him off the bench last year when
he got there and just had that energy
and then just let him go
but but when i have him with lebron and
a.d when they were healthy
i i don't your offense is different when
lebron and a.d are on the floor it's
different if you have russ in there if
russ is there and you know one of those
guys is subbed out
then i can i i feel like russ can work a
little bit better under those
circumstances well lebron and a.d like
this is not you know breaking news but
their best lineup is the two of them
with three shooters around them with
defensive minded players
around them and maybe if you want to
appease a.d like one big man who can
play a chunk of minutes at the five so
he's not banging at that position with
his body uh anymore so i just i look i i
don't believe
i don't believe there's going to be an
epiphany with russell westbrook i think
they're going to come to training camp
he's going to want to be the starter the
new head coach is probably going to make
him the starter and we're going to be
right back on this hamster wheel once
again where russ you know is playing
hard out there but is going to the rim
is causing turnovers is not fitting
alongside lebron day deed there doesn't
i don't see what the solution is
with this mix you're not going to trade
lebron doesn't seem like you're going to
trade a.d you're going to be able to
kind of fill in the holes around them a
little bit with a new roster a new group
of minimum contract players but you're
going to have the same old problems no
matter what coach is coaching that yeah
and i give you credit you said this from
the outset last year you knew this was
not going to work chris thanks for
joining us safe travels to uh
save save that seat save save that one
save you know that oh we weren't rolling
on that wrong i nailed that one i did i
nailed that one i didn't i was cored
that
i'm saving it for my own archives all
right that's chris mannix senior writer
for sports illustrated